(music)
My name is Mark Zoack. I'm a professor
of geophysics at Stanford University and
the director of the Stanford Natural
Gas Initiative. I have three degrees in
geophysics and undergraduate degree from the University of Arizona and a Masters
and PhD from Stanford University. I did
a postdoctoral fellowship at the U.S.
Geological Survey. I originally came to
Stanford to complete my graduate
education. I had an undergraduate degree, I worked in the oil industry for two
years and I realized that there was an
awful lot I didn't know with just a
bachelor's degree and, uh, when I applied to graduate schools Stanford was the best
school that would take me and so it was
an obvious decision. In my research group
we do a variety of things. We study
reservoir geomechanics; we take data that
comes from oil and gas development
activities and we try to figure out the
subsurface. We take core samples from
these reservoirs and try to understand
them under realistic conditions and we
do regional studies mostly trying to
understand the forces that are in the
crust how they cause earthquakes how
they affect their large-scale geologic
processes.
(music)